SO EVERYBODY, PLEASE WELCOME
AHMED MOHAMED.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HELLO, MAN, HAVE A SEAT.
AHMED.
NICE, NICE STANDING OVATION.
ISN'T THAT NICE.
>> YEAH, IT'S REALLY NICE.
>> Larry: I KNOW.
YOU ARE SUCH A COOL KID
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
BEFORE WE START, I JUST HAVE
A QUICK NOTE TO YOUR
TEACHERS, PLEASE DON'T BE
ALARMED, THIS ISN'T A WALL
OF EXPLOSIVES BEHIND US,
OKAY?
I JUST-- THESE ARE JUST SOME
CLOCKS WITH TIMES FROM
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE'RE ABSOLUTELY SAFE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR.
OKAY.
OKAY, FIRST THINGS FIRST.
HOW LONG DID IT TAKE YOU TO
MAKE THAT BOMB?
(LAUGHTER)
I MEAN, IT LOOKS LIKE A
PRETTY COMPLICATED EXPLOSIVE
DEVICE.
>> 20 MINUTES.
>> Larry: SO YOU WANTED TO
MAKE A CLOCK S THAT HOW IT
STARTED.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: WHAT WAS YOUR
THINKING, HAD YOU MADE A
CLOCK BEFORE.
>> NO.
>> Larry: REALLY.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: SO WHY DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE A CLOCK.
>> IT WAS SOMETHING REALLY
SIMPLE TO MAKE.
>> Larry: BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
LOOK SIMPLE.
THAT THING LOOKS PRETTY
COMPLICATED.
DID YOU HAVE TO LOOK IT UP.
>> NO, I DIDN'T HAVE TO LOOK
IT UP.
THE ONLY THING TO LOOK UP
WAS THE RECEIPT FOR THE BOX.
>> Larry: REALLY?
WAIT, SO YOU ACTUALLY
THOUGHT THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF HOW TO MAKE A CLOCK
YOURSELF.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: SO IS THAT WHAT
YOU ARE REALLY PROUD OF,
LIKE ABOUT WHEN YOU DO THESE
TYPE OF THINGS, THAT YOU
FIGURE IT OUT BY YOURSELF.
CUZ I CAN'T EVEN FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO A LEGO CLOCK LIKE
THAT, YOU KNOW.
BUT A REAL CLOCK.
>> IT IS REALLY SIMPLE TO ME
BECAUSE I BUILT MORE STUFF
THAT IS VERY COMPLICATED
LIKE.
>> Larry: LIKE.
>> CPUs AND SODDERING THEM. BUT
THE CLOCK WAS SIMPLE.
AND SOME OF THE PARTS WERE
SCRAPPED OFF.
SO THAT'S HOW IT GOT EASIER.
>> Larry: THE HORRIBLE THING
ABOUT THIS WAS YOU GOT
ARRESTED.
WE HAVE A PICTURE OF YOU IN
HANDCUFFS DO WE STILL HAVE
THAT PICTURE.
THAT WAS AMAZING, YOU WERE
WEARING YOUR NASA SHIRT.
AND I REALLY WAS TAKEN
BECAUSE I LOVE SPACE AND
NASA.
I WAS LIKE WHAT, HOW COULD
THEY DO THIS TO THIS KID.
WAS IT A LITTLE COOL TO BE
ARRESTED?
KEEP IT 100 PERCENT.
>> I MEAN IT DOES GIVE YOU A
LITTLE STREET CRED.
>> IT WAS KIND OF COOL.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: I MADE A CLOCK.
>> THE ONLY REASON I FELT
COOL ABOUT IT BECAUSE I KNEW
I WAS INNOCENT AND I KNEW IF
I DID TAKE IT TO COURT I
WOULD--
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: THAT'S RIGHT.
WAS ANY PART OF THIS SCARY
AT ALL?
WERE YOU EVER SCARED THAT
SOMETHING MIGHT HAPPEN OR --
>> I MEAN, YEAH.
WHEN THE COPS ALMOST MADE ME DO
THE NAENAE BACKWARDS WHERE MY
ARM WENT ALL THE WAY-- .
>> Larry: DOING THE NAE NAE
BACKWARDS, HOW WOULD YOU DO
THE NAE NAE BACKWARDS.
>> THE COP, WHAT THEY DO,
YOU SEE RIGHT HERE, THEY
PULLED MY ARM ALL THE WAY UP
WHERE I COULD LIKE-- LIKE
HIGH ENOUGH.
>> Larry: GOOD LORD.
I CAN'T EVEN FAKE DOING
THAT.
SO WHAT IS COMING UP NEXT
FOR YOU?
SO YOU ARE AN INVENTOR.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: YOU REALLY LIKE
INVENTING.
DO YOU HAVE OTHER INVENTIONS
YOU WANT TO DO, ARE YOU
INTERESTED IN THAT KIND OF
THING.
>> YES, I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN IT.
I WOULD SAY MY NEXT
INVENTION WOULD BE A-- A
SIDE HOVER BOARD.
HOW DOES THAT WORK.
>> THERE ARE THESE FORWARD ONES
GOING FORWARD AND REVERSE
>> Larry: ONE THAT MOVES
SIDE TO SIDE.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: NICE.
(APPLAUSE)
SOMEONE MAY THINK THAT MIGHT
LOOK LIKE AN EXPLOSIVE
DEVICE AND YOU CAN GET AWAY
ON THE HOVER BOARD AND GET
AWAY SIDEWAYS.
BECAUSE YOU LIKE TO BUILD
INVENTIONS WE WANTED TO GIVE
YOU A NICE LITTLE GIFT HERE.
WHAT WE DECIDED TO DO WAS TO
GIVE YOU, YOU HAVE A CLOCK.
WE THOUGHT WE WITH GIVE YOU
A WATCH.
SO THERE YOU GO.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> Larry: ITS HE'S A NICE
WATCH.
COME ON.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO
YOU HOW TO PUT THAT
TOGETHER.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THE TIME.
>> Larry: WE'RE ONLY
KIDDING.
ACTUALLY A NICE NEW APPLE
WATCH I WANT TO GIVE YOU.
AS A GIFT FROM THE NIGHTLY
SHOW.
ENJOY THAT, MY FRIEND.
KEEP INVENTING.